we start out with things that we have in
common and that we should be able if if
we are truly convinced of our beliefs we
should be able to discuss without anger
and hostility and listen to one another
because there are things that even
though I may not agree with the faith of
a Muslim there's things that I can learn
from his commitment to God
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala you guys been married
for 35
years he's getting close Okay 37 up or
down 40 40 okay first thing I need to
secret of that I've been married nearly
5 years so the first thing I need to ask
you guys is please share me tell me two
things that I can Implement in my
marriage that would last it for 40 years
cuz it's so far it's 5 years so we we
have a Christian marriage and so that's
very important to us is is the
spirituality love is a decision yeah
good love is a decision and keep a keep
a happy attitude okay forgive okay how
did you guys deal with dispute so if
she's upset with something Etc like if
my wife is upset with something how do
you think like how do you deal with it
like any time you upset her she tends to
talk about it more and I tend because
she's the woman they express the more I
might say I might say he'll pout what do
that mean he'll hold it in and and kind
of Stew inside I'm like that I'm I'm a
bit stubborn I'm St do inside and I
would rather discuss it and hear what I
have to say and then share what you have
to say but we we end up working it out
okay interesting but okay thank you for
that so look do you know anything about
our beliefs that coincide with
Christianity cuz we we some I know that
you consider Esa a prophet at least
that's my understanding and U and and
I've had some Muslim I have some Muslim
friends I think they believe in one God
too don't yes I know you're monthe we
believe in the one God yeah so we
believe that Jesus had a miraculous
birth yeah uh we have a whole chapter on
his mother did you know that
we have a whole chapter called Mary so
it's about her and the miraculous birth
she had because the the Jews in their
belief they call her an adulterer and
they insult Jesus so we don't believe in
that we believe she was a holy woman a
very righteous woman one of the best
woman who walk this Earth we are told we
believe that Jesus was a miraculous
birth um and uh we believe that he's
done Miracles uh with the permission of
God he will come back we believe in his
second coming he will kill the
Antichrist which we know as Dalal we
call him the Dalal um and yeah our
belief system is um very similar we we
can marry Christians we can eat from
black it is okay to marry Christian so
as a Muslim man
surprises yeah so as a Muslim man I'm
allowed to marry a Christian woman but a
Muslim woman cannot marry a Christian
man okay um the reason behind that is
because as a Muslim I not allowed to
force my Christian wife into Islam but
we believe that a Muslim woman might
might be coerced into Christianity maybe
so that's the reason why a man can but
yeah Muslim woman and Muslim man cannot
both marry Idol worshippers so pagans
like we we agree that idol worship so um
one of the main things Islam came down
to was to um abolish idolatry so that we
are told that God is one uh he there is
nothing like him he's self-sufficient um
the only thing that we differ with the
Christians maybe is that we don't
believe God is a man that Jesus came and
died for the sins of the world we don't
believe that but you know other than
that we've got very great similarities
is there any misconceptions you guys
about Islam anything that you like okay
we've heard this oh I I I respect s
sincere worshippers of all of all Faith
now I I I think that there are obviously
some ways that are closer to truth than
others but I do respect when I see
sincere conviction coming from people of
various faiths and and when I see people
that are following the principles of
their faith I'm somewhat critical of
people from my faith who are only very
shallow Believers and who don't follow
through for instance I don't drink
alcohol I don't I don't eat pork I'm
vegetarian and so heal is a religious
sorry uh both okay both because I think
my body is the temple of God and that
God wants me to take care of it but I
think God has given me a way that is the
best for me to live so I would say for
both health and religious reason so so I
appreciate that about uh Islam and I
have traveled in areas where Islam is
prominent like turkey tury I'm I'm from
Turkey yes love turkey we love turkey me
and my wife go there we just go to eat
we love the food yeah yeah so uh I I
lead uh tour tour groups to Istanbul and
to ismir in the area of I'm from I'm
from Kiser it's business Capital yes the
areas of the seven churches so so that's
where we go in fact we were just there
last year and so we try to help the
Turkish economy out in that way so uh so
so I respect people
who are sincere and follow through in
their faith commitments whether that's
Christian or Islam or Judaism and I
think that when conversations take place
we should start out with things part of
the park I'll tell you no that's all
right that we we start out with things
that we have in common and that we
should be able if if we are truly
convinced of our beliefs we should be
able to discuss without anger and
hostility and listen to one another
because there are things that even
though I may not agree with the faith of
a Muslim there's things that I can learn
from his commitment to God and and for
instance I I think that some Christians
need to do better on the principle of
surrender to God submission to God and I
think Islam is very strong in that
regard so yeah I mean I mean yeah it's
lovely like with us what's are you a
Unitarian or a trinitarian so are youan
unarian or a trinitarian do you believe
God is one trinitarian are okay so okay
so um that's that's that's interesting
for us but but we did we explain that
very carefully yeah is that one God
manifests in three persons and I'm sure
you've heard formulations I can tell
you're in formed and so I I I'm sure you
heard how Christians formulate that and
I know that to our friends who are
Islamic and Jew and Jews I know that
sounds inconsistent to them one God
manifest in three person because I do
affirm strongly uh the shama the Lord
Our God the Lord is one and yet I do
believe that Jesus is God's own son and
was was born of a virgin and uh those
those types of things that are taught in
the scripture interesting yeah that's
what Allah tells us in the Quran that
tell the people of the book that we come
to Common terms between us and you that
we worship God alone you know the main
thing is that Islam is just like any
kind of idolatry any kind of thing it's
just a pure worship the god like for
example I'm sure you guys have some kids
M how many kids two sons brilant two
kids I got three do with yeah so it's
like with us from our perspective just
just quick I don't want to hold you guys
down was a beautiful day you don't want
to speak to me all day so it's like
imagine if your kids how old how old are
they uh 31 and 33 okay good so and we've
even got one grandchild as young as this
lady look she has a granddaughter yeah I
know I know I know she's she's just 35
we know that you know yes so the thing
is good so the thing is here is that
when our children like grow up like
would you not want them to give you the
credit that belong bels to you in the
sense where you looked after them you
changed their Napp diapers sorry diapers
yeah um you looked after them you
protected them against harm way um from
our perspective the Trinity is like for
example that imagine your kids grow up
and say you know father I'm going to go
and thank Derek there yeah it's it's to
us it's like for example we believe that
you know it says I God I'm a jealous God
by God so we're seeing that that true
worship and asking should be directly to
God so from our perspective it's like
that's why we have so much similarities
that's why we wey to have a discuss with
Christians to meet in the middle or
somewhere where we can say we should
give our pure devotion to God when we're
asking him directly we don't we are very
against going through prophet Muhammad
so no muslim is allowed to go and say oh
Muhammad in your name we go directly to
God so from our perspective is like
there should be full direct and focused
towards God he's the one that sustains
us he's the one that created us if we
ask for anything we don't go to the
Muhammad or any other Prophet we go
directly to God that's from our
perspective though right but yeah I
understand and I do want to say I would
be happy for Christians to be as kind
and congenial with others about their
faith as you are about your faith yeah
they are I love Christians are lovely so
I want to affirm you in that regard nice
to meet you have a nice Ali allly yes
what kind of food do you guys like am
like uh what kind of Fe are you guys
into oh we eat a lot we actually have
eaten um we had a tour group we just ate
a sand we
like do you like Japanese yes well is
there a good Japanese Japanese PL is
there a
place it's I never knew what to get in
japanesee vegetarian oh oh no they might
they might have tofu there's a place
called there's a place called there's a
place called her and torus the black
bean is very nice and they kxa and they
do have a vegetarian option I'm sure I
like it when they take the rice and roll
it in seaweed Sushi they do very good
sushi I like that Sushi well I want you
to know you're a good representation of
your faith you know what you are also
because you're such a lovely gentleman I
sometimes speak are we have hostile
Muslims and Christians by so refreshing
to speak to a person from the book who
yeah thank you very much thank you thank
you sister thank you have a nice day
thank you yeah I mean I mean I mean guys
I'll be honest with you I don't know if
you guys can see but I am kind of
getting Goosebumps now why am I getting
goosebumbs look at the Civil dust
discussion that we just had look how
lovely they were we came we spoke I told
him about Islam what we believe I didn't
want to get into an argument Etc because
you need to understand a lot of people
people are La Muslims sometimes are very
uh fixated in arguments Etc sometimes
toed is not you convincing the other
person or making an amazing argument and
breaking them down and making them look
stupid and Trin doesn't make sense no
sometimes it is how you leave a
discussion sometimes it is your manners
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
said I came for nothing but to perfect
good character and again I'm not trying
to say I have that the point is when we
get into these discussions assess you're
like a doctor Di signals spoke to them
they're obviously a bit elderly they
don't have that much energy you know
they're walking Etc I'm not going to get
into a fullblown debate Etc about the
Trinity we spoke I told them what we
believe in Islam my job is to convey the
message I I I hope I have done that
alhamd it was a brilliant discussion
lovely couple spoke about marriage spoke
about food spoke a bit about Trinity
spoke about toed and we left it
alhamdulillah and may Allah subhana tala
allow it to be a means that they accept
Islam and alhamd
these little things before I came to
Islam it was the character and the way
Muslims would treat me that would play a
role in my decision-making factors so
may Allah subh allow to not be something
that we just
utter like a robot or something that
inshah it is we
embody Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urg need your support
this donation will be a for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you will in
be reaping the reward click the link and
donate what you can